grinsen backe oliver pocher der war in
katar und hat sich dort mit einer
deutschlandfahne und einer ein bisschen
kleinen regenbogen armbinde ablichten
lassen ja toll ein ganz mutig also
peinlicher grafisches mit peinlicher
geht's eigentlich schon nicht mehr man
muss sich einfach klarmachen dieses land
hat
gastarbeiter die unter klaren
bedingungen gehalten werden müssen ihre
pässe abgeben es gibt ein cover system
wo der wo der arbeitgeber entscheiden
können wie lange er arbeitet wie werden
schlecht bezahlt
6500 bis 15.000 gehen die schätzungen
auseinander sind gestorben weil die
bedingungen so schlimm sind wir haben
ein düsteres unrechtsregimen hinter
zugegebenermaßen glänzenden fassaden und
dann stellt sich herr pocher hin und
feiert sich für den mut dort einen
regenbogen binde getragen zu haben
dieses land geht unter der knute und ich
kann einfach nur sagen augen auf münder
auf das ganze ansprechen und nicht
solche scherz aktionen und so tun als
wäre man jetzt der mut bolzen der nation